welcome to this video playing drain you
from Sweden this is actually from master
sooner Birkins from Denmark but may be
living in Sweden looks like that and
he's around here with a very low rating
that's a really strong five-minute
player he had five minute top of 26 yeah
this is chang he is normally at least on
24 25 something like that so probably
having a bad run okay i'm playing with
d6 here going for a quickie 5 set up in
this line of the bogo let's see what is
doing a 3g 30 kg three really want a
quickie five after d5 i need to insert
Bishop takes to d2 ok don't want to
blunder the bishop do to Queen a form
but this is in fact quite ok for black
in fact my experience from from studying
those type of positions for my my book
project is that if Black gets in a quick
f5 he is ok almost all the time and here
white is spending lots of time wow talk
about ambitious play ok so do I go 96
yeah I guess so it really should be ok
going to the to the dark squares IAM to
f4 or to h4 h4 is also a sensible
sensible square
there's also Queen H form possible Jeff
not sure about that what might be best
here
I have no idea for coming and he also
has a g4 that he needs to worry about
after move like age 39 f 4 I am not sure
what he's doing then my night only eight
this is a problem but other than that
should be very very okay okay just move
the Queen yeah maybe he really threatens
to take this
hmm yeah maybe he does now castles I can
take on age 3 with a little trick Bishop
f4 EF I attack be too so i have this
discount to play I am I night only hmm
and I am Bishop f1 does an interesting
how do I get this night into the game
gee 697 looks very very slow
see 697 every difficult position didn't
think about that one really with it with
g5 I was thinking to play with b5 here
trying to get some some count to play
that way yeah thats that surprises me
really that he takes now I get a six now
I get a six year for for my night
impossibly deform night f5 he has night
f5 though but I have queen bee 72
difficult maybe I need to play jus six
ok.can castle on ok I must I must play a
move night f5 yeah not really not really
a move I like to play what neither five
is too much cannot allow it see 594 is
probably just answered by a typical
exchange sec so not a good idea if he
goes there i have Queenie five at least
an ID em
okay i can take the six simply 24 25 26
PAH dreadful simply dreadful this
position I must have misplayed this I
mean g4 and it was interesting but I
don't really think it can be any good
definitely not to be refuted I'm worth
what I played but I have my my doubts
about the general concept now this is
just busted it's not even a hint of gone
to play Queen before we should be 60 but
yeah maybe i can i can really just just
straight him straight trade on g6 that
sets it's really enough
yeah I think just trading on g6 is good
but he can play em play mini-museum I
really have no counter play well that's
that's still surprising slightly passive
move I know if for at least a cell maybe
I'm not really threatening to take it
but there is some some glimmer of hope
Bishop g2 I have this 93 f for business
it's not that apparent how he should win
now I aim for Bishop f3 getting more
pressure on the pawn and maybe now I'm
threatening to really take it now he
really has lost control over this
position d 5 or not i I'm spending too
much time here I'm a pawn of you how
weird is that check oh no bra Harvard
check okay check come on black rosanna
camel I'm just stupid gym I could have
one on time but you know I really hate
that after such a blonde of hesitant I
mean it could have been an interesting
endgame still but you just just need to
force to play some some stupid moves
because of this time control and I was
completely busted of course I really
don't want to win such a game on time so
let's let's check him yeah I wasn't
really really weird
how did how did this happen yeah g-form
ought to move yeah it makes some sense
if i get in at 5 i'm certainly opening
the position in a way that i want but it
still looks looks weird to have all
those we can squares maybe you can still
do it and i really don't know maybe here
i should just take g tool I mean you
don't want to do that really but maybe
it's what I need to do yeah he is
threatening to take the pawn definitely
I have no compensation if he just takes
that on a form this is why I went here
and now one night xt500 simple technique
over I felt that there was something or
I can just take be fine ah 95 and black
resins basically it's the most important
point in the position Oh No okay ah man
ok I went here and I can still take 25 I
mean why don't I do that yeah and here i
was surprised by this but what really
has controlling matches he really is I
simply have a bad position here he went
went here he already can take on on g6
first but I was thinking that simply he
can just mean sorry
let's this and now why didn't he take
this is this is weird this is just just
killing me and that's it I really have
have nowhere new move here whatsoever I
mean this is check checkmate this is
made so this is why I was really totally
busted and then well some are
step-by-step he let me back into the
game which was tricky with the time and
everything but white is still better
probably but I get somehow got this porn
that I really I really don't want to win
such such such a crap shoot here I mean
it's a it's just chat after i blundered
to the rook here it's just I just don't
want to win this on time okay thanks for
watching